Fans of That '70s Show probably noticed the
show's plot start to unravel in the second
half of the series.
For example, some may have noticed the years
on the license plates become inconsistent
around season four.
The first three seasons display a new year
starting in 1977.
After the fourth season, the years all stayed
the same, suggesting four seasons passing
in a single year, compared to the previous
four seasons in four years.
Perhaps the writers made the mistake of starting
a sitcom based in the '70s a little too late
in the decade, and were forced to remain in
a single year for continuity reasons.
However, superfans may remember there being
a Christmas episode every season, yet all
of those Christmases would have had to occur
in a single year.
Once fans started to think about some of the
plot holes in the later seasons, they may
have wondered if everything they saw on the
show was true or if something else was going
on that fans weren't aware of.
Some fans have taken this to the next level,
proposing a theory that might make a little
too much sense.
Let’s check out the Eric theory that changes
everything on That '70s Show.
In Season 4 Episode 15, Tornado Prom, Eric
Foreman goes to prom with his group of stoner
friends, but he forgets to bring his girlfriend,
Donna, who is stuck at the radio station where
she works.
This is a classic Foreman blunder that we’ve
come to expect from Eric.
Being the lovable character he is, he decides
to rescue his stranded lady.
While doing so, a tornado is seen behind Eric's
car, but he doesn't notice it.
The episode goes on as usual, and the two
are reunited.
They make it to prom and everything seems
great...at least on the surface.
Some fans, especially at Entertainment Weekly,
took a deeper look at that episode and came
up with a fan theory that would change everything
about the show.
If you remember, while the prom is going on,
the parents of Eric and Donna are watching
the news regarding the tornado when they hear:
“This just in: the National Weather Service
has canceled the tornado warning.
And updating our top story: a local teen is
in critical condition.”
You need a good ear to hear it, but the theory
goes that Eric Foreman never actually made
it to Donna.
Instead, the tornado caught up to Eric, who
is the local teen in critical condition.
As a result, Eric falls into a coma.
This would explain many of the inconsistencies
throughout the second half of the show.
Let's say this was true; how would this have
affected the rest of the show?
The theory is that since Eric is in a coma,
and not dead, the show continues based on
his memory and how he believes certain situations
would unfold.
For example, a few seasons later, Eric decides
to move to Africa to become a teacher.
This is a little out of character for Eric,
but it also could mean that Eric was falling
deeper into his coma.
This could be something Eric always wanted
to do but couldn't because he'd always been
stuck in Wisconsin.
Following that, Eric is replaced by new character
Randy, who could be seen as Eric's imagined
version of his older self.
It could also mean he is falling even deeper
into his coma and losing perspective on what
is plausible.
This idea is bolstered even further when Fez
marries Jackie and Laurie on two separate
occasions.
Another example of fuzzy logic in later episodes
is when Eric's mom, Kitty, begins to record
everything that Eric is missing.
This is potentially a way for Eric to stay
connected with what's going on at home while
he is in the coma.
None of this makes sense in the surface-level
plot, but Eric doesn't know that because he
is drifting further and further away from
reality.
In the series finale, everyone is waiting
for Eric to return from Africa on New Year's
Eve.
He does so in the last few minutes of the
show, and a warm-hearted reunion at a familiar
spot concludes the series.
“I wish there was just some way to take
the edge off”
“Edge, you are officially off”
Of course, fans weren't satisfied with this
and had to work this event into their theory.
Let's assume Eric was supposed to make a recovery
on December 31, 1979, when the show was supposed
to end.
The theory suggests that Eric doesn't make
it back home, that he is still in a coma,
and that this is his last goodbye to everyone.
His memory allows for one last time to remember
all of his friends and family back home.
Then, when the series ends, that is when Eric
allegedly dies.
It's a dark theory, but when you think about
it, it could make sense in the end.
It's undeniable that there are several plot
holes in the later seasons, and maybe this
could be explained by something like the main
character being struck by a tornado and falling
into a coma for a year.
Or maybe the writers just lost the plot.
Perhaps we’ll never know!
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell, so you don't miss a single one.